yeah welcome to the rematch of them
let's game just to just finished um and
let's see the Queens gambit and sloth I
go for 93 see you want RK is coming up
with the main line I'll go with III I
don't really know any other line I mean
I don't really my knowledge she is also
not perfect but it's better than with 95
let's put it this way okay so i think i
need to drop back now my damn Bishop f4
at least this is 101 were valid well it
way to play yup we should have four
or I know if five is not good oh I
Bishop g5 Bishop g5 may probably has a
five okay put it on a form
hmm yeah maybe he's intending to play to
play a c5 what about night h 2 nite a 2
was good yeah we cannot go to the 6i
exchange play you five young looks like
I'm winning this Bishop I mean
exchanging it for night and this is an
important piece on I'll be gaining them
some very useful space maybe push up a
five before something like that cannot
take on before I have Brooke b 1 b 7 at
the end so Bishop a 5 be 4 C 5 I take it
and it's got a very bad structure after
that yes I am at the end allowed me to
take the question is do I want to take
and with this configuration and
preventing c5 on account of the capture
maybe let's play a couple of improving
moves
it's not so clear what what is what he
is playing next age six or something
like that
ok so i can take and I can take em takes
both the Queen I don't know wait if I
take is nuts not so right
yes c5a son is a valid way to play okay
come on need to need to speed up a bit
maybe look see one
c5
you facing he tries nation
hmm
five year after c5 I don't want to take
the 95 looks like he's got a decent
setup
can I'd really play d5 on c5
hmm
I don't know I don't have a really good
good idea in this position maybe try
Knight to c4 a tiki can play you five
now I was hoping that this isn't so so
great
if you just allows night see form then
then this is some basically over yeah we
must play that ok can I go can I
sacrifice the spawn probably not take a
Nazi fool
24 is a good news I cannot play the F
porn after that
24th good young yeah well f3 is some
shaky move anyway and we do for even
prevent that I don't really see move
after 24 he's attacking the porn like
how much four times I'm not quite sure
why he is investing time here at Sur ok
he didn't appreciate the strength of the
smooth yeah f3 looks looks like what ok
still I need to do it it weakens the
dark squares but I cannot give up the
porn and we can weakening so it's really
a really ugly
yet shopkin can go to f1 and going to be
6 this is my idea if I get the Queen
self and managed to make a 33 let's get
the Queen's off first I think he needs
to exchange our queen e 7 is a
possibility but check so no I had this
is this is again something that I can
try to they can try to play form for an
advantage by making position is so it's
very good
No
yeah what the position name group t2
check if I've made check time morning
checkmate I don't know his police it's
doing a he put up lots of resistance in
both games quite quite remarkable yeah
some somewhere around here I think I'm
controlling the game again but it's not
it's not clear at all yeah well
interesting games thanks for watching